[Music]  mr ward  how would you like to make 50 million  dollars  on a warm summer's evening on a train  bound for nowhere i met up with a  gambler  we were both too tired to sleep so we  took  turns of staring out the window at the  darkness  the boredom overtook us and he began to  speak  he said son i've made a life  out of reading people's faces think  about it  everything we did all  [Music]  we did something just for us  you ready to play there's 200 million  dollars in the vault beneath the strip  with a 32-hour window to get it out  find the safe this should be a simple  in and out  it's not too late to go back  [Music]  what  they're not what you think they are  they're smarter  they're faster they're organized  they'll be timing  what is this there's a goddamn  zombie tiger that's crossing the line  know when to fall down  [Music]  you